when the police try to gain entry using false pretenses
help stand your ground
chat from there
no you don't got a warrant have you got a warrant
have you got a warrant
no you haven't you're not pursuing a suspect
I know the law so just go away
why are you doing that
you can speak to me here perfectly fine
I can hear you you can hear me
partners there
why do you need to speak to her
no no it's not you can't be trusted you lot
we had this last time didn't we yeah
sorry
I know why you're here
yeah because the nurse made an accusation
right you can do that here
I don't know how coming in the house is gonna
have you listened to the recording
so you're not even heard the recording
of this alleged fret
you do know what I'm talking about
kids Planet Nursery
phoned me when I was in the car with my wife
and I said the place is gonna be teaming with Ofsted
the authorities
I want all your staff drug testing right okay
they got up
they got on their iOS and got defensive
because our sons been in there two days
come home with a shitty nappy twice
okay so they got defensive when I told them I'm getting
the offer is on them
then it was well
I've got to call the police
you've made a threat
made no threat
go listen to recording
cause they have to have them recorded
it's a nursery
then come back
and then you'll realise it's a waste of time
cause I'm not coming down that station
to get locked up for 20 hours like he's always do
what's it about then
why why
why
right so so alright
I want to check on your children then
I've just made one
no yeah that's how it does work
go and get a warrant if you wanna come in my house
go and get a warrant cause I ain't doing this
she gonna break in yeah
a concern for kids
do it through the window
they'll all come at window